but one thing that also came up
yesterday is both you and Michael go for
two new ministers he said Justice
Minister you both have a cater bringing
back the death penalty in the past so
that's something that you're happy to
stand by now look I mean I've been asked
about this previously on a number of
occasions as well I made it I made a
comment a long time ago and said that it
would only be appropriate back then so
not now but back then you know when we
have the most horrendous and heinous
crime this is not something that is
relevant to today's political debate or
discourse at all
I am very much focused in my job as
employment Minister you know supporting
what we do continue in what we do when
it comes to growing our economy and
getting more people back into work you
might not think it's appropriate to ask
it but it is appropriate to ask whether
or not you still believe it I've told
you already exactly what when that
comment was made a long time ago it is
not long ago it was on question time I
said again it was made a long time ago
and it is not relevant to today's debate
but do you still believe it well look I
said it back then when I was asked about
how I made the point back then when I
was asked the question in terms of the
content with which I felt it would be
relevant it is not relevant today's
political debate and the subject that
I'm here to discuss with you